hey everybody welcome back to LED live
where light exposes darkness with the
light of Christ you know we live in a
world today where people are addicted to
all kinds of things and today we're
gonna talk about what can you do to
overcome find out on this episode of LED
live so welcome to the show guys I'm
excited today I want to talk about
overcoming I want to introduce you guys
to Chad and foddy a cruiser they have an
awesome ministry called anchor point
films they do documentaries on a variety
of subjects we'll put the link in the
description below so you guys are going
to want to check these guys out talented
work you've traveled around the world we
want to hear about this overcoming
because we get a lot of questions in our
ministry like yeah okay we hear about
you guys talking about the TV and all
this media addiction what do we do from
here yeah good question yeah we probably
we probably traveling around speaking on
overcoming for pry around 15 years or so
maybe a little longer and you know I use
before in my experience growing up I was
I was a heavy drinker I would drink
myself to sleep at night I was smoked
you know and and one of the things that
I that I noticed with it all is that it
was you know you enjoy an addiction when
it begins not the addiction itself but
the substance but then what I found is I
would typically wake up empty you know
like you it feels good initially
obviously who would do it I mean nobody
would nobody would like smoke or drink
something or chew something or whatever
right if it made you empty what you did
it right but it's you know I would
notice like I'd wake up after and just
wouldn't be happy like realizing at a
relatively young age you know like this
this isn't bringing true happiness and
so ended up you know over years of
struggling you know going back to
sitting you know I try to quit the
cigarettes so I found out that I could I
could quit tobacco at any time I
couldn't quit tobacco but I could I
could quit smoking at any time and I
could go to chewing and I could quit
chewing at any
and I could go back to the cigarettes
you know but I couldn't actually stop
being addicted right now and often what
you find is that people people go back
or they they maybe you know you go from
heroin and then you just now you're just
doing like smoking pot or you go from
smoking pot and you're just like
now you're just a fiend to like caffeine
or something like that so obviously like
a void if you don't fill that void with
something it's just gonna manifest
itself in some way shape or form and
something else absolutely I mean yeah so
originally what led you to those habits
like what what was it that you said okay
I'm gonna start drinking or I'm gonna
start smoking you know part of it was
friends meaning like part of it was you
know you're just growing up around
alcohol it was you know it's in the home
you know cigarettes were smoked yeah
they mean they were they were in the
home and there in the cupboard or they
were there and you know I was given my
first cigar from from dad and very
rapidly just became addicted so I'm
gonna assume you did not grow up in a
Christian home or was this Christian
well it was actually a Christian home
yes yeah it was a Christian home but you
know they just didn't think anything I
can see one of these things the
background I came from was a Christian
religion that doesn't really believe
that the body really matters I've even
been told that specific thank God
doesn't care about your physical health
he only cares about the spiritual right
and all things in moderation right if
you just you know smoke a feel you don't
smoke a pack a day little heroin here or
you know as long as you're moderate you
know it's no nobody would say that the
idea of moderation and everything is not
legitimate I mean like there are certain
things that are just better to avoid
altogether no and that church would not
have taught that but the idea that your
body doesn't matter but you know I
learned well number one I wanted to quit
myself even before realizing what the
Bible actually said I just thought like
I knew it was destructive I was in high
school and into college and I was moving
furniture and just carrying like sofa or
a couch up somebody stairs I just been
huffing and puffing Wow and I realize
like I'm 18 years old I shouldn't be
huffing and puffing like yes you know
yeah and and so I wanted to quit but it
was so so hard yeah it's the it's the
habitual nosov the activity right yeah I
think God designed us to be habitual
with lots of things in
you eat every day you come home every
day I mean there's these habitually
engage in and the devil knows that so
all he does is he kind of tweaks that
and sends us off in this sort of
destructive habitual patterns outlet
it's built into our DNA right and we
actually should have good habits that's
why it's like you know overcoming
destructive habits rather than just
overcoming habits all together because
we want it's good to have a cycle of
good habits in your life they should
just be a part of your life for sure and
with that you know concept of being
bombarded with things you just have to
turn it around and do the same thing
with good things right if you're
bombarded with billboards if you're
bombarded with commercials whatever you
just have to replace that with good
things so now you have we call it your
billboard for the Lord and you'll have
the Word of God with you at all times so
when you're feeling that stress or
whatever turn to that so now you're
bombarding your mind turning it on
better things so you got a thing time
yes basically because if you're wanting
to get out of addiction you know it's
there you know it's kind of lurking in
the background you need to pre think
whenever I feel like I'm getting into
that space what's my plan of action yeah
yeah and talking about some of the
history and I know I know you know this
and anybody who's taken like a first
year psychology 101 course in college
they know about a man by the name of
Phineas Gage Phineas Gage was a guy who
in the 1800's worked in Vermont on a
railroad crew and they're drilling down
into into rock in Vermont because it's
kind of a rocky place or someone like
maybe here in Tennessee or California
not as big a mountains as California but
mountainous areas and you know so
they're hilly and so forth so they're
blowing out you know with this you know
explosive powder like dynamite trying to
clear out areas so they're drilling down
into the rock Phineas
he's a foreman of the railroad crew so
he has you know the intellect to be able
to lead other people as he's drilling
down into the rock one day they would
put you know the explosive powder at the
bottom put some sand on top of it and
use a rod called a tamping iron to pack
it down before the the fuse would be
ignited and one day he's tamping it down
and as he does some way somehow it
ignited
you know exploded shot him
the cheek and blew out the top of his
skull and it just continued on like a
missile and so the amazing thing was I
mean you would think in 1800 someone
would just die right I mean literally
lost part of your brain and so but
within minutes as he was conscious he
would stand up with a hole in his head
lost part of his brain he would run up
to people and be like I just had a rod
blow through my skull he would literally
tell everybody around him what and
people were you know you know what on
earth just happened and he would tell
people the story right there and he
ended up losing one of his eyes and but
what's you know this is this you know
just to give you an idea of the brain
kind of a you know crude illustration
here so the top portion of the brain is
the frontal lobe there if you imagine
someone lying down looking up the top
part there is the frontal lobe and you
know basically the rod went through this
part of the skull lost this part of the
brain the rod didn't stay in the skull
it kept going but long story short what
were the results in this guy's life you
know he had what we would call an
accidental lobotomy you know losing a
part of his brain on accident before
that he was a foreman of a railroad crew
faithful husband and father well-liked
by fellow religious fellow workers he
was a religious man he was in regular
church attendance until that day and you
know September of 1848 and but what
happened that's fascinating is will
happen after the accident you know it's
not that he lost all of his intellect
but something really changed about about
Phineas and so after the accident he
would become very emotional and angry
about things you know I thought well you
might get a little emotional if you know
part of your brain was blown out right
sure it might be a little emotional you
know but but it seems to be much more
than that so he lost interest in church
and spirituality he became irreverent
and prone to excessive profanity so he's
swearing he's cursing all the time after
this and he lost all respect for social
customs he became burek very
irresponsible went from a prized
employee to the unemployment rolls
he ended up forsaking his wife and
family and it said that he joined a
traveling circus
so really it's like the filter or the
the moral compass shot out yeah yeah so
now he has no no filter exactly and
because sometimes we just think like
maybe this is just a way this is just
the way I am you know like I'm just you
know some people are religious it's not
me it's just who I am and that's kind of
the way they're wired but I'm not wired
that way but sometimes actually our
interest in moral spiritual things can
actually be with what's going on within
our frontal lobe right and so if it's
functioning well we may have a greater
interest in spirituality morality our
decisions will actually be better will
be healthier but something could be
actually physiologically happening to
our frontal lobe that could be making it
less likely for us to be interested in
spirituality you know and you one of the
powerful things that I know you share
these things - that the frontal lobe is
the scientific studies reveal that the
frontal lobe is the seat of spirituality
morality and the will there's actually a
lot more to the frontal lobe it's not
like that's all the frontal lobe is
about its portions of the frontal lobe
are implicated in ADHD meaning like
actually portions of the frontal lobe
can physiologically shrink in people who
have ADHD and actually you know I mean
we know that overconsumption of media
can actually shrink the frontal lobe but
the good news is there's actually things
we can do to reverse this all so that we
can actually grow the frontal lobe at
the same time so which we're not going
to go into right now but one of the
reasons we become addicted to substances
is because we get depressed that's one
of the reasons I mean like if you are
happy all the time would you need
something to try to make you happy right
no I we are just literally beans that
want to feel good all the time yeah and
a society I from our point of view and
observation is we're just addicted to
feelings right we feel good with the
music we feel good with the movies we
want to feel good with the food we want
to feel good with all these things and
it's just feeds into this just need for
that totally so I'm sure addiction is
right I'd step away from everyone
yeah and one of the other things that
the frontal lobe it's where you do
you're not just your deep thinking but
love that's where love takes place
interesting and and a lot of times
you'll hear from people who are
suffering that way I don't feel like I
love my family if so and sort of died I
don't think
even care right and that's depressing in
and of itself to think that you think
like that
and it no wonder you know like the devil
wants to attack the place where you do
your thinking about you know what are
you gonna do today your spirituality
your love all of this and it just
destroys society alright so when you
drink or you do drugs
it's literally attacking the frontal
lobe it suppresses the from the action
of the frontal lobe that's one of the
things that takes place and so we kind
of like that as humans in general
especially let's say you're maybe
depressed or you are you're thinking a
lot about something it feels good to
just shut that down you know so that you
don't have to think about it but the
reality is like I said it does feel good
initially but it never gets better
because of it I mean it's temporarily
better because you don't think about it
right and sometimes you know there's
there's other things that people do
sometimes like sometimes people use
forms of meditation where they just shut
down their brain and that sounds great
because then I don't have to think about
my issues but really is that fixing the
issue it's like if I have a massive leak
in my you know under my kitchen sink or
something like that and then I just like
I'm not gonna think about it my eyes
look at it yeah yeah it's like right
there yeah it's like the leak is still
there right it doesn't fix it because I
choose to you know calm down for an hour
right like no like certain things have
to be actually dealt with and we want to
do things that are healthier than just
shutting down our minds and television
or you know excessive video games these
kind of things help us to shut our minds
there's escapism yeah but it doesn't fix
the problems that the leak is still
going on studies show that actually that
type of meditation at the moment you may
feel relief from it just like when you
pray you have relief from your stress
but the difference is is after your
prayer you have resolved something
trying to combat inclusion about it
whereas the studies showed that with the
meditation afterwards the stress goes up
higher because you haven't really solved
any problems just like you don't solve
problems when you sit and vegetate in
front of the television you don't solve
problems when you sit and drink and you
lose lose your mind so that you don't
deal with your problems but we were
meant to grapple right to grab their
problems and grow from them right you
know aren't you happier on the other end
so just like if I go to the doctor and I
have a cholesterol problem he says okay
well you need to take a statin based
drug and you take your statin based drug
but your cholesterol is you still have
that underlying issue and you haven't
solved the problem yeah per se yeah
you're just masking the symptoms like
most pharmaceuticals are doing they're
masking the symptoms so we're just
masking the symptoms with entertainment
or you know heroin addictions or tobacco
or you know alcohol whatever it is it's
just masking the symptoms and the great
news is with these things you can be
healed and heart disease our candy heart
disease can literally be reversed which
is awesome you know and one of the
things we share which we won't go into
in any detail here but we have a seminar
called the gut brain connection and
which is literally literally changed my
life from depression to happy I mean our
greatest desire as human beings is to be
happy there's just no question that is
our greatest desire and there's you know
when we talk about the gut brain
connection we talk about what goes on
and the gut can actually make you happy
or depressed literally what's going on
in the gut which is fascinating so why I
mean can you give a short little thing
yeah just the bacteria that's - yeah so
the bacteria is part of it and there's
there's several things to go into detail
they found that they found both in
children toddlers who have a greater
diversity of gut bacteria are actually
more social more positive and more
outgoing children who have less
diversity toddlers who have less
diversity you've got bacteria have more
tantrums they're more antisocial they're
just not as happy and so I mean gut
bacteria so so real quick how do you get
the maximum amount of get back yeah
great question
just wide variety of food yeah so here's
the thing once again like you can many
people we think man I better go buy some
you know probiotics and and and and that
is an option but the only way to keep
that in is to continually for the rest
of your life boat by probiotics they
don't if you stop they died yeah exactly
so so where do we naturally get them
because you can imagine a thousand years
ago like people weren't going to the
local fryer and
wherever you know and buying their
probiotics but in so the real place is
that when you eat whole fruits and
vegetables I mean you get within them
like an apple has a hundred million
different bacteria on it I shouldn't say
100 million different a hundred million
bacteria on or within the Apple and so
and there's a variety of different kinds
within different strains within that
Apple so if you eat apples alone you get
the strains that come from apples but if
you add to your diet pears well now you
get some new strange that you might not
have gotten from the Apple some of the
similar ones but then other ones and as
you eat you know plums and peaches and
you know cherries and whatever and you
know greens and so forth you're now
getting a variety and so you're adding
to what researchers call your microbiome
the the you know this pool of bacteria
within your gut and so but they also
found the same thing with alcoholics so
they did they did a study looking and
this isn't in the in the Proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences they
they looked at it was a small study of
60 alcoholics they found that the
alcoholics who had less bacteria were
they struggled more to overcome they had
more cravings for alcohol which is very
fascinating one of one of the friend of
ours who's a meth addict he he share
with me something that I thought was
quite perceptive he said you know we
were sharing this this science and what
the Bible says about it because the
first place that talks about this in
history
that I know of is actually in the Bible
the first scientific study in all of
recorded history according to an article
on the National Institutes of Health
says that Daniel chapter 1 is the first
scientific study that they've ever been
able to find don't you love it don't you
love it I mean once again science
proving the Bible and it's like now
thousands of years ago you expend
writing and talking about this and now
only are we seeing that in our
scientific world today and we're like
hey something's kind of line up totally
to--and the thing is that they say that
you know you would look at these things
and in the in the first study is
actually a study on the gut brain
connection what these young men were
eating infected affected not in fact it
affected their cognition sir right so it
actually enhanced the way they fought
and now as people replicate this today
they find a very similar experience that
what you eat can actually enhance your
cognition who would have guessed that
what goes in here
affects what is up here but this is what
this is what they're finding so it can
make you happier to press it can help
you to lose weight and you can lower
depression levels within two weeks by
doing this I'll talk more about it later
on on what that is and also it can help
or hinder your social skills so meaning
like people may find that their
antisocial issues may actually stem from
right here they may just think it's just
who they are but as they change their
diet significantly and as they become
happier they're less likely to feel just
introspective and maybe just more social
so our friend who is a meth addict the
thing that he said was there's one thing
that all true addicts have in common and
he said it's their diet interesting he
says he said you never see and you never
see it like a meth addict oh man I could
go for a salad
they literally cheese its Doritos you
know whatever exactly so you're not
getting you're not getting the nutrients
a hey but you know many you know you can
find like Oreos or vegan you know does
that mean it's good for you getting all
that good I love those commercials beer
vegan yeah it's healthy now right like
you know just because vegan doesn't
necessarily mean healthy right at the
closer you get to the whole food itself
right meaning you know you can cook the
food but but in general like the closer
you get to you know something that's non
refined is what we're saying so yeah
these these are things that are it
literally as I began as my diet began to
change it just it literally changed my
you know levels of happiness got rid of
depression it literally changed my life
and so uhm yeah but you know some of the
things to overcome maybe you could share
with that a bit so some of the things to
overcome is chronic stress you know a
lot of us kind of live in that phase of
chronic like all the time stress yes
yeah number one killer has to be I mean
literally our world two income
households yeah everybody's stressed out
everybody wants the big house the boat
the whatever and they're killing
themselves trying to achieve that yeah
well on the flip side he could be
stressed if you're just a one income
household because you realize your seem
to be short all the time versus
everybody else so it works both ways and
some of these same principles can help
like changing your diet can make you
less stressed with the same stressor ice
meaning so like it does
mean just because there's we many times
think the external stressors are what
make us stress but there's certain
people who like all the stresses going
on around them and they're totally at
peace like Jesus you see him before
Pilate they're literally gonna kill him
and Jesus is totally correct he's
sleeping in the storm I always think
about that story and I'm just like are
you sleeping when literally these
fishermen and they've been on a boat so
Kate they are not new to this type of
stormy environment that sure and they're
fearful for their life yeah here's Jesus
asleep so for example people say that
heart disease you know stress causes
heart disease right but during World War
two
in Norway when when the Nazis came in
and took over they took all of the
animal products from them and gave it to
the soldiers so the common Norwegian
people could only eat plant-based food
plant-based diet during this time and so
during the time of war when stress
levels are super high their stress
levels went down and their heart disease
stress went up or the stress we're not
sorry but the effects of stress on their
body weren't there because heart disease
went down interesting Samari diet
actually trumped the stress itself and
actually reversed heart disease or would
help lower heart disease during the same
time they were ridiculously stressed and
then after the war when they started
eating these foods again heart disease
came back up again so less stress yet
more heart disease less stress doesn't
make more heart disease but the diet is
what was actually causing so sometimes
stress can be dealt with better if we're
careful with our lifestyle in general
right yeah but it's still something to
overcome because some people may be
eating well but just like constantly on
the go and and if you are always at that
kind of level of stress your liver will
always let out glucose to deal with the
stress and then your insulin increases
and then you could become a diabetic and
be skinny but still become a diabetic
because your your body's creating that
yeah so just something to think about
anyway so then things to overcome also
as anger lack of forgiveness we do a
whole night just on that because lack of
forgiveness drives many people to
addictions you know it's awesome
I watched a documentary one time on the
Holocaust and it was from the
perspective of all of the twins that
were experimented upon yeah and one of
them who I think her sister even was
passed away or something and she
literally forgave all of the doctors
shoot after the war she went around to
in Germany knocked on the doctors doors
that she could find and was like I
forgive you for what you're doing and
she lived a wonderful life and the rest
of the Holocaust survivors you know they
get together every single year at at
that same time and they would you know
go over ash wits and and you know
remember all the people that went
through that terrible experience and
they literally lived this perpetual life
of stress and all this or this person
that just literally forgave them had a
wonderful life Wow so that's my goodness
is a powerful very amazing and you think
like if you're not forgiving you're not
happy and if you're not happy you want
to find something to make you happy and
so you move on to it could be a literal
substance like a drug or alcohol or it
could be you need to fill your life with
video games if you feel your life a
television or or bad relationships you
know to go from one person to another
it's like this addictive thing and so
the reality is we believe like the Bible
teaches that our body is the temple of
the Holy Spirit says that first
Corinthians three first Corinthians six
six and so God says I don't want you to
destroy my temple my bond your body
right and so we don't want to do
anything that would cause harm to us or
to other people and he wants us to be
able to live away world we're free from
these things and happy at the same time
right another thing you want overcome is
judgmental thoughts you know as humans
we struggle with that it's right always
you know looking at somebody and judging
oh why they do that or why do they do
this well I can't they do this and you
know we're always passing judgment and
we need to learn how to overcome that as
well because it eats you up right you
know and destroys you but also eating
disorders or unhealthy food that's
something that you know needs to be
overcome as well yeah big problem in in
in today's world unhealthy food you know
it's not even just you know meats or
things that are you know sort of the
heavy end of the spectrum I mean it's
just a simple like like crackers you
know just things with you read the
ingredients on there and there's 50
ingredients and it's like is it food
right did I'm guilty of that man yeah
it's like I go to a you know a buffet
table at a church or something like this
and it's like you know do I pick the
chips and you know the what do you yeah
sugar is a very addictive sugar as well
yeah it's a big row and if I remember a
sugar also can affect your frontal lobe
if you have you know that that rush yeah
I think it's like 2 grams or more or
something you know and it just you get
that hit and it's like you're not
functioning properly anymore and if
you've ever noticed like if you if you
have an increase in sugar you're just
like you want more of it you're like man
yeah yeah some more dessert today you
know they're simple food doesn't taste
as good afternoon yeah well like fruit
is where you should get your sugar from
right right and some people just don't
like fruit I'd rather have the
concentrated you know food but another
thing with that is that it's not just
sugar but it's the way they combine the
three together mm-hmm
so sugar salt and fat the way they
combine them they actually do scientific
studies to figure out exactly how to get
you addicted interesting yeah and so
these the we we heard of a guy he was
sitting in a plane you know the
proverbial sitting in the plane met this
guy whatever and we've met the guy
hotels yeah we know the guy that sells
it ok so he's sitting there and this
he's sitting with a chemist and this
chemist works for a food industry and
he's telling him very openly all the
things they do to make people addicted
to their foods and he's so proud of this
they do this his way he said what do you
do he's like I designed foods that give
people so they can't stop eating it like
addicted to the food yeah yeah and so
they're just talking for quite some time
and then finally he asks the guy oh and
then and then the man sitting there says
oh our church puts on seminars to
overcome what you do what you do and he
looks at it and he said so we're
essentially working together yeah and he
looks at him and he's like
are you a seventh-day Adventist and he
said yes and he said oh we know about
you we know about what you guys do he
said but there's not enough of you to
counteract what we do and I was like wow
incredibly you got to think like they
have scientifically honed in and it all
boils back to money yeah I mean you know
the more people buy their product more
money everybody makes repeat us they
don't care about your health no it's all
about the mighty dollar yes yes why if
you've never gone that far you know you
if you don't if you make the choice to
just never go that far you're always
gonna be better off yeah yeah
so also other common addictions you know
smoking drinking drugs pornography lust
television too much television gambling
or fill in the blank you know people
have their thing that right maybe nobody
not on this list and it's just it's a
personal rights truck so you can apply
these principles pretty much to Anatoli
you get yourself into that's a
destructive behavior you know it's
interesting about pornography and lust
too is that you know when you look at
scans of a pornography addicts brain the
the you know the energy that's taking
place I mean their brains can look as
bad as a drug addict to somebody who's
addicted to pornography and not only
that like if it's so a friend of mine
was doing a paper in in a just you know
regular sex secular college he's not a
paper he's doing a speech on the effects
of pornography and he was you know he's
a guy and he's sharing how it makes men
more likely to abuse their you know wife
or girlfriend or whatever and so he's
sharing some of the negative side
effects of this and he said you know and
people got angry with me and he said you
know who got angry and the male's it was
actually the females really you would
think you know but I think it's cuz guys
know like you know anytime a guys looked
at porn actor they don't walk away from
it going like yeah that was really
enlightening that really that really
like makes me care more about women or
whatever like everything they know deep
down so they hear the effects know like
yeah man I know that's true but I I
don't know why the women would get angry
with him I don't know I mean I just I
can't say what it is but well I've heard
that it's just as much of a female
problem in today's world as it is
problems but this was like 20 years ago
this was a long time ago - I mean I
think you're all relative yeah so I just
think sometimes girls don't understand
the dangers right they may not
understand what it does to a guy running
like it's you know like and that baby
fizzy yeah he's like you know they just
see it at the face value oh he's just
looking at things he shouldn't be
looking at but it goes a lot deeper or
they may not mind y'r your brain your
brain yeah so yeah those are just some
things to overcome you know but also
this is one of our this is one of the
most powerful quotations that just sums
up all of psychology in one sentence
never forget that thoughts work out
actions repeated actions form habits and
habits form character I actually love
this progression because you know really
gets around to the you know all of us
have been tempted in our brains right so
but we know when we linger on those you
keep thinking about them that that moves
to something else I mean everything
begins with the thoughts and so to see
the end conclusion it does affect your
character totally and in many times
people try to change bad habits or they
try to change their character but they
continually go back to the same bad
actions because ultimately there are
thoughts have now been changed right
because what you think about will work
its way out that's right you think about
something over and over and over and in
general you end up doing what and that's
why the Bible describes it is you will
reap what you sow that's right you put
the seed in the ground those thoughts
are those seeds and they're eventually
gonna grow into something totally
totally it goes along with like Romans
12 us to be transformed by the renewing
of your mind like if you're gonna be
changed the Bible said thousands of
years ago if you're gonna be changed
it's gonna take place right here right
like that you you know we want to just
you know I don't know we just want to be
changed but the reality is unless our
mind is change ultimately our actions or
our habits in our character the world is
looking for a magical pill like you know
I want to lose weight
can't I just swallow something and it
does that for me but a lot of people
don't realize it takes a long time
actually put the weight on and sometimes
it takes twice as long to take it off so
it's a lot of work yeah that
you know needs to go into this as well
yeah you know and one of the things we
share too is there's there's a few
essentials for overcoming number one is
to have a desire to overcome you know I
remember when I started smoking it was
sitting on a park bench in a park with
my friend and some guy walks by and
we're smoking and some guy walks by and
he says hey kids quit while you can and
I thought you know way I'll never I'll
never get stuck smooth like I'm just I'm
having fun you know like I enjoy this
you know kids you catch this slight
little buzz and it feels good you know
and you know months later you can't quit
you know so but I didn't want to quit in
the beginning so you have to have that
desire you know the Bible even talks
about that but also you also have to
have an open mind if what you're doing
is not working maybe you have to learn
something else or implement something
else to overcome now you don't want to
just have your minds there there's a
saying like you can have your mind so
open that your brain falls out you know
right and we're not talking about that
like don't just do anything to quit you
know right and I would suggest not
shutting your brain down to find victory
right like once again cuz that doesn't
fix the problem like there's a deeper
issue that needs to be healed
whether it's physiological or whether it
is emotional we think it's always
emotional we think it's always just
mental but sometimes there are
physiological things as we've already
stated that could be making us depressed
and if those are reversed it makes us
happier and then it's easier to overcome
and sometimes you have to change the
pathway like in the brain you know I
remember hearing one time that it was
like you're looking your brain is kinda
like you're looking at a wheat field
right and if you walk through the wheat
field once it's not really might find
that path again but you're not really
gonna find it but if you walk that path
every single day you're gonna like it's
gonna stop growing wheat and you're
gonna have this solid path and in order
to get rid of that pattern you got to do
a new path so for me as well I I had a
major drug addiction in my early 20s and
I literally had to move change my
location change my people I even changed
my job I changed my surroundings because
it was just that pathway and all those
associations so in order to you know do
that sometimes you need drastic measures
as well
elderly do brain is electrochemical and
electricity always follows the path of
least resistance so if you have a habit
it's essentially the biggest wire in
your brain for that habit so it's always
gonna go that direction unless you do
something to change it but as you're
talking it was making me think of how as
we get older people talk about being set
in their ways you know it's like um you
know I can't change now I've been doing
it for so long
I'm just set so it kind of really drives
home the importance of when you're young
if there's something you can change it
seems like it would be easier to do it
while you're young and instead of 50
years later you've been doing it you
know for so long I remember a drop
shadow - doctor once and is this guy
he'd been smoking since he was 5 years
old he walks in the doctor's office he's
65 and we went outside of the patient
room and we're looking at his x-ray of
his lungs and it's just there's black
there's like no definition at all you
can see is black where his lungs are and
we walk back in the room and she told
him you can go on you if you quit now
you won't have to go on oxygen
immediately she's like but if you keep
going you know you're probably gonna be
on oxygen here pretty pretty quick it
was just like it had already been
decided by that habitual 60-years just
couldn't give it up you know yeah in
many young people I think they look at
like grandpa and grandma depending on
what grandpa and grandma were like but
often people look at older people and
they think you just become moral by
getting old yeah like like if I as I get
old but it's not the case man I've been
over to light as a kid you know I'm over
at my friend's house you know we're
probably ten and grandpa's probably 70
of this kid that I'm visiting and
grandpa's got a stack of Playboy you
know like being old doesn't make you
holy like it doesn't like the change has
to take place somewhere it doesn't just
happen like you will be the same person
you've been unless something changes you
know so yeah and you may be working with
more broken propensity slike if your
parents were addicted to whatever
alcohol you may be more susceptible to
alcoholism or it may be more dip
for you to overcome that based on your
past his family history but I believe
any of us can change right totally
absolutely absolutely and one of the
things you know we always give a little
disclaimer we say hey you know we're not
your doctors you can test these things
but you'll see any of this the stuff we
share is totally simple stuff it's not
that you know revolutionary but one of
the things I mean it is but you know the
Bible says in Romans at revelation 14
verse 1 it says and I looked and lo a
lamb stood on Mount Zion and with him
144,000 having his father's name written
in their foreheads one of the things
that Bible says about like in prophecy
that God will write his people's names
in their foreheads and we know in the
Bible Bowl from the old and the New
Testament that the word name means
character and it does actually you know
we don't think about it but it does
today - at least historically we don't
use this term as much anymore but there
was a time where people would say oh
that that family has a good name where
that business has a good name and you
don't mean that it like rolls off your
tongue well you mean you mean that like
mutation they have a great reputation
they have a great character people know
something good about them and God talks
about his people in the end having hid
the father's name written in their
foreheads you know the forehead of the
brain is right behind that it is the
frontal lobe right and so if we have
God's character and God's character is
summed up in his law but the law is
summed up in one word and that is love
right and so true love would never want
to hurt somebody else so if you hurt
something if you love somebody you
wouldn't want to steal from them right
you wouldn't want to take their husband
or their wife away from them you know
you'd want to be kind to your mother and
your father and each one of the
commandments is summed up with love the
last six have to do with love toward
people the first four Commandments have
to do with love toward God and the Bible
says that this is what God's people have
in the frontal lobe is we've already
seen is affected by over consumption of
media drug use these kinds of things and
so God wants us and you notice a true
drug addict you may think all they're
very loving they're very kind but it
becomes very selfish sure and we may not
think that and they may I know some
people would get angry hearing that oh
you should never say that but it's a
reality if I'm wanting a drug I'm
thinking of who thank you
I'm thinking around especially in family
situations I mean your your now you know
removing you know money out of the
family to go and satisfy yourself I mean
so yeah what do you think it's only
affecting you it's affecting everyone
yeah this is an interesting point you
look at an Old Testament picture of this
the high priest used to wear something
on his head they called it lighter some
translations say and on that mitre says
holiness to the Lord you know this is
this is what is to be the thought of the
mine imprinted on the mind is holiness
to God not just not just for my position
but as a representation of the people of
Israel in total holiness to the Lord you
know and one of the things to begin in
the Old Testament Deuteronomy 624 says
and the LORD commanded us to do all
these statutes now statutes another word
for law so the LORD commanded us to do
all these laws and then it goes on to
say it is for our good always meaning he
calls us to do the commandments for our
own benefit it's not like you know
sometimes people look at the
commandments are gone they're like oh
there's just these you know God just
brings up these laws and says do this
don't do that this is good that's not
good but it's just random well maybe
he's not right but he actually he made
everything and so what he's saying is
the things I asked you to do
I should have beneficial for you and for
everybody else they're actually meant
for your true happiness right you know
God wants you to be happy and so and
once again all of his laws if they
actually point toward true love how
could they be bad meaning like yeah yeah
it doesn't make sense that God would set
something like that in motion for
thousands of years and just say you know
that really wasn't that important no
yeah you know it's like you know I mean
I mean I did that then but it was really
no big deal so disregard that yeah I
mean we're just moving on I mean God's
not like that but as well like you know
what if you were living in the
antediluvian world right and you got
kept out of heaven literally because you
broke those Commandments and then you
get to the end of the world and those
people are just flowing into heaven
you're kept out and you're like wait a
minute why am i outside of the city when
they're doing the same thing that does
make any sense at all and so you know
God is the same yesterday as he is today
and that's consistent all the way
through yeah absolutely you know and
some of the frontal lobe killers things
that can actually negatively impact
we've already talked about drugs can
negatively impact the frontal lobe lack
of use you know if you're not using your
brain that's why you know people as
they're moving you know our whole life
we should be using our brains as much as
possible we should be reading we should
be learning right like learning some new
skill doing gardening getting you know
various things that are beneficial for
our brain so there's studies I've read
about where over time the mind can more
or less crystallize if it's not being
used and people who have been like
college professors for example have a
much less chance of that happening
because they've spent so much time
thinking and teaching and training that
when they get into their their older age
they just still keep thinking yeah you
know it never goes away their mind is
ecology running learning and so that
crystallization never really happened
yeah yeah and I see with my grandpa he
was that he was a professor and he was
learning I mean up until like you know
started having some serious health
issues he was reading he was learning
all the time and so I mean they found
that people with college degrees have
less less likelihood of having
Alzheimer's and you you you know those
you know people who don't have it you
may let me just keep studying you don't
I mean you don't have to get a degree to
continue studying we all should be
learning instead of just spending the
rest of our lives on video games and
television right like what you say for
muscles if you don't use it you lose it
it's no different with the brain yeah
that's right another one our head
injuries so head injuries you know
affect the frontal lobe whether it's you
know you fall off the bike hit your head
and you have damage like literal
physical damage car accident or a car
accident
extreme sports with you know yeah and so
today we seem to be adrenaline junkies
and we always just try to warn people
with no helmet yeah exactly
isn't Tennessee one of the states where
you don't have to wear a helmet you
don't have to man
we just went to a convention a couple
states over and and I remember this guy
pulled up on this Harley right next to
us no helmet flying down the freeway it
was just like wow I mean if you if you
get into an accident that's it you're
done yes and that's freedom like your
freedom but you have to be holiday you
don't have to I remember in Illinois I
worked in the hospital and there's this
boy and girl teenagers and he was
sitting at the light and he's holding on
and then he was gonna take off and then
all of a sudden an SUV comes in front of
them which is taller and he has to hold
his brakes all of a sudden she had her
hands on her hips she flies over his
head hits her head on this you be total
brain damage she comes into a hospital
all these teenagers are there I mean she
just her brain swells from just that
little bit it doesn't take much and she
ultimately died Wow so but it's just it
doesn't take much to damage the green
but even if you live like Phineas Gage
you may be a different person
right you don't I mean and that's what I
was gonna go back to is Phineas Gage is
you know he he basically lost self
control yeah if you will
yeah and so we go back to the football
players I forget what the acronym ins is
like CBF or something Co P I don't
remember but they've discovered you know
the repeated injuries even with the
helmets on it's the same kind of
description they become different people
you know they become violent they become
angry they become and then they may have
dementia later in life too so yeah not
not who they really were
yeah so I told its interest totally and
so head injuries and I mean we've met
people with serious head injuries that
they are different they are like you
know they're different people afterward
and also a lack of nutrition so you know
not eating in a healthy manner it causes
a negative impact on the human brain so
and the brain craves carbohydrates
that's what it thrives on right not not
refined ones like sugar candy and candy
bring some whole food yeah exactly and
the brain just loves it it can only
store about two minutes of glucose
itself so it depends it relies on the
rest of the
to feed in mmm little side no because I
know somebody watching will say no no
that's not true don't eat carbs are bad
for you sure and and but all of the
longest-living cultures on the planet
every single wonder that are known as
the Blue Zones today eat between 50 to
80 percent of their diet or carbs the
largest living people there's no that I
know of and I don't think that's been
found yet you don't have any culture of
longevity that's a high-fat diet eating
group of people people point out what
about the Inuits or what about the Masai
people in Africa the reality is both of
those are short living groups of people
and so and even long before refined food
came into their diet not when we find
frozen Inuits
you know in their 40s with with
atherosclerosis or hardening of the
arteries so it's not it's not because oh
now they eat you know sugar or something
like that
actually as the as the Western terrible
diet began to get into them they
actually began to have lower levels even
though they were eating a poor diet but
because they were getting you know more
or less into their attrition it's
exactly strange but but the reality is
we're not saying eat candy bars eat
Twinkies no like that's not where
they've got to be the right type of
cookie exactly you want to eat the whole
plant-based food so what yeah we'll skip
the liver so yeah okay yeah we will show
we will show this so here's a modified
fast or a cleanse to do for heavy
alcoholics drug drug addicts and
diabetics and I'll tell you more about
it a little bit but basically if
someone's a heavy alcoholic a severe
drug addict or a diabetic type one or
two what you would do for for one day is
is to actually first for two weeks I
would actually suggest it that's you'll
see the one day comes later is to eat
just water fruit veggies whole grains
and no oil for two weeks for two weeks
so you're eating a very very simple diet
and you're gonna see the science behind
in a moment how this can actually help
with depression and anxiety and why it
would help with victory over addictions
so that's four and there's a reason why
we say for heavy alcoholics drug addicts
and diabetics we have another plan for
people who are more standard lifestyle
but but are still trying to overcome
something because these people like a
heavy alcoholic can go into you know
what
seizure they can literally have seizures
by getting off alcohol so and so one of
the things that may help us get it you
want to make sure they get enough
nutrition while they're coming up some
people actually have to go into a center
because they literally been drinking so
much alcohol that they can I mean they
can close to die because they'll just
stop breathing so it's their body has
been there's bodies literally fighting
to get that and it's like well I'm gonna
shut down a few exactly so they're
physiologically addicted to it you know
and so you want to you want to be eating
plenty and so if you are one of these
people eat plenty during these these two
at this two-week period do not try like
fasting fasting so that's why we call
them modified fast because you're
avoiding certain for everybody else for
the first day you just eat water and
fruit this is for one day if you're not
a diabetic or have serious health
complications you know talk with your
doctor about it but you're gonna see why
and just in just a little bit you know
the Bible says is we stated earlier
first Corinthians 6:19 and 20 what no
you know don't you know that your body
is a temple of the holy spirit which is
in you which you have of God and you are
not your own for you were bought with a
price therefore glorify God in your body
and in your spirit which are gods and so
our bodies are to be this temple and we
want to use them wisely we don't want to
to destroy these bodies you know we're
gonna talk a moment for ace about a
super drink so it can increase energy
and endurance prevent kidney stones aid
in digestion and elimination regulate
the body's temperature and bring about a
feeling of well-being yeah very few of
us consume as much as we should
so what's this super drink water water I
got it God's beverage is what I call it
and you can't improve on God's beverage
so I I have a question on this I saw
this one study that they did on all
kinds of liquids they literally went
through soda wine water juice you name
it like hundred or two hundred and they
actually this particular study said that
the top thing to consume was high Bic
hibiscus tea in water is do you know
anything about that yeah actually I have
I have seen information on that I think
it can lower blood pressure it's
actually quite good to drink but when it
come in ghent so yes I biscuits tea if
you're gonna have some kind of tea drink
some of these herbal type teas rather
than a tea that has caffeine because
caffeine can actually have an effect of
[Music]
well yes addiction yeah well it can
cause addiction there's various other
things and once again we're trying to
get away from anything that is addictive
especially if you have an addictive
personality so once again so you stopped
smoking and now you're like a fiend with
you know Starbucks or sugar and so if
you're looking to overcome we're not
hoping that you just like transition
down to a less harmful addiction because
they check it out on YouTube you know
it's like I know everybody like if
you're watching this on YouTube it's
like you can look up in I think it's ABC
News sent one of the reporters to check
to see the effect of caffeine on the
brain so this lady goes into maybe
you've seen it she goes in and she has
an MRI scan before she's had any
caffeine they show how much you know you
know energy or blood flow is going to
the brain MRI blood flow
yeah they show the blood flow yeah the
blood flow that's are they show the
blood flow to the brain that's right
that's right and so what happens is then
she drinks one Starbucks coffee and then
she goes back through the MRI and the
blood flow drops by 40% to her brain
after having one cup of coffee from
Starbucks so and the reality is perfect
health is dependent upon perfect
circulation right so if you are dropping
the blood flow to your brain by 40%
right that's not the best thing for
often no no can it be okay like yeah you
may live just as long or you live long
drinking coffee but the reality is what
if it makes you it increases the
hormones and so forth that make you more
stress so and if you're more stressed
what are you more prone to do heart
disease are you tempted to go because
think about it like a smoker what do you
what do smokers often do it they want to
smoke they want to smoke
yeah and they also want a coffee so it's
like you're going back and forth like
these two things are working together
right and so you don't want to the
coffee want one health center actually
found them that specifically they the
people were coming to their program the
ones who are most likely to overcome the
smoking were the ones who would also
quit the caffeine so if you keep on the
caffeine and I was not able to stop the
smoking and the chewing and
till I actually let go of the caffeine
you might have a headache for five days
a week but but once you get beyond that
you know on the other side of five days
a week the headaches begin to go away
and you actually end up feeling just as
good and then potentially even better
then you did once again drugs make you
feel like I need it to feel normal right
but the reality is someone who's never
drank this stuff has never needed it I
was totally not yeah totally totally so
this this is quite powerful maybe you
can tell us about this study on so
there's a dr. pitz out of Ohio and he
wanted to prove whether or not water
helped you have endurance and so what he
did is he put people the same athletes
he had them to three different things
one of them they walked on a treadmill
or all of them were it was walking on a
treadmill but the first group they were
given no water they just were asked to
walk and this is the results of just
walking on a treadmill so the zone of
exhaustion is when they hit are over a
hundred and one tenth okay and so once
they hit that that was around two hours
they were done so they were not given
any water and they were done after two
hours
then the next group were given water as
they desired it hmm so what does that
usually mean when you when you feel
thirsty yeah yeah like I want so this is
what happened with that group they
lasted longer close to six hours hours
long yeah hours longer they lasted
longer but then they had another group
and what that group they they had then
they measured every loss they had of
liquid you know whether it be through
breathing sweating whatever and they
measured and then they make you drink
yeah that and whether you wanted to or
not right right they made you drink and
they just kept walking and walking and
walking like okay I get it it is it
doesn't present indirect you know so it
was very amazing and that's actually the
reason he did it is because one of the
reasons not the only reason but one of
the reasons they were able to finally
make it to Everest Mount Everest to the
top to the top of Mount Everest was
because they started to increase their
water intake Wow there's other things of
course we don't have time to get into
that but water was one of the reasons
and so that's why he did this study
trying to figure out if that's really
what a simple thing that all of us have
access yeah all you know start with
living a healthy life by just drinking
water yeah and so if you're feeling
stressed if you're feeling anything like
that just start drinking water and I'll
show you something here real quick a
person would have to lose ten percent of
her body weight in fluids to be
considered dehydrated Wow but as little
as two percent can affect athletic
performance cause tiredness and what
double critical thinking abilities and
where do you do your critical thinking
your frontal lobe and so right there
we're mostly water right yeah but your
brain is even more a bigger proportion
of your brain is water than other parts
so where are you gonna feel it first
because it says 10% is considered
dehydrated but as little as two percent
already affects your brain your critical
thinking and that's your frontal lobe it
makes a lot of sense if you go back to
physiology because if if you know
perfect health requires perfect
circulation your blood is mostly made up
of water you know the thicker it gets
yeah the harder it is to pump yeah yeah
you know the less oxygen you're getting
to your brain because of that so they
have a turtle works synergistically
totally totally it doesn't they have a
they have a term for when it gets like
that like if they call it sludge blood I
mean it literally is like sludge moving
through so just drinking blood fluidity
they do study after study on the effects
of blood fluidity on our health so and
water is one of the key components that
helps us have good blood flow yeah so
like you're saying a 6% of the body's
water in the brain is 73 plus percent
some say more but some say more yeah now
does it matter drinking water like like
like we brought before tea so like you
know I have to put like tea in water and
I just put it in the refrigerator and it
kind of steep sit on it on its own it's
just fruit tea or whatever like that
just to add a little flavor to it is
that different than just water it
is actually soap meaning there's there's
probably nothing wrong with having some
you know some good herbal tea here and
there so you know I like to have a nice
drink maybe you want something like that
but when someone Loma Linda University
did a study looking at every kind of
basically drink and that's that's
relative myth not every kind but they
looked at several that like fruit juice
they looked at you know coffee tea you
know they various different kinds of
things and so what they found is that I
mean I'm doubt they did hibiscus tea
specifically but they did probably
regular you know green tea or black tea
or whatever and what they found is that
everything outside of the water
consumption increase the chances of a
heart attack and just water itself they
found that people who drink five or more
cups of water per day
compared to those who took drank two
cups of water per day they decrease
their chances of having a heart attack
by 50 percent by drinking five or more
cups of water a day and that's thinking
I mean that's the number one thing
that's the number one killer right so
this is significant so drinking and and
so but the other even even you know
fruit juice and these kind of things
actually increase the likelihood so like
things that you think are normally a
pretty healthy it's better as much as
possible to drink the you know the fruit
they're not the water itself because
water hydrates you all these other
things are are digesting you have to
digest it and your body longs to dilute
it and so it'll pool water from you to
dilute it interesting and and so that's
why water is the only thing that truly
hydrates you because the body doesn't
need to eat you know use the equilibrium
to like make it you know what about
Gatorade you know you know I don't know
of any I've seen the commercials I mean
it works right no I mean I'm sure there
is some there is some hydration taking
place at these are people would die
because there are people who never drink
anything but but you really just they're
getting salt yes yeah so yeah you need
your electrolytes cuz you don't want to
dilute your your blood so much why
drinking too much water and then you
just get into a lot of trouble with that
but like when I'm really sick throwing
up you know that kind of thing and water
just is so difficult to just take down
I'll do catering right it's like I'm
territory things you're not going
and you can ever do anything else but
you know purple grape Gatorade yeah
throwing up yeah it does it's like I can
drink it like I mean in a normal setting
it would mean it's like oh that's so
sweet but when you're in that state it's
the only thing your body can take and so
there's a place in time for things but I
wouldn't make that my normal choice yeah
yeah so it lowers blood pressure
drinking water it elevates your mood so
again you know your mind helps detoxify
the liver which is very important and
maintains or lose weight maintains body
temperature that's huge you know if you
can keep yourself hydrated you're less
likely to overheat over heat you know
don't need as much air-conditioning and
that kind of thing and also it clears
your thoughts which is so important
because if you want to come overcome
addictions if you want your mind to be
in the best situation to make the best
decisions you need to make sure you're
hydrated you know it's just something we
take for granted but if you're feeling
down at the middle of the day yeah you
could be literally you're either
slouching your this watching or you need
water you need to rehydrate just like a
flower starts you have to will so will
we're no different we need that water to
perk us up again so it sounds you know
like all really can it help that much
but it really does some of the simplest
things are the most important right now
right and we just need to be reminded of
those very simple things you know I want
to overcome something I need you know
fresh air good food and water yeah yeah
I mean those are things that we have all
have access to totally totally otherwise
you're really starting it almost a
deficit in trying to overcome and I was
I was we do these almost little we do
some health programs at church and we
have like these little TED Talks you
know at the culmination of them and one
of the doctors from our church you give
a presentation on willpower and how your
willpower can be increased or decreased
by the habits and choices that you're
making in your life and so this goes
like right or wrong yeah totally if
you're drinking that water your
willpower is going to be up yep and
you're gonna better able to overcome
because you have more willpower and your
bank
available then if you're at a deficit
you know back here and you're just
dragging yeah I'm thinking of e'en
telling them what left is up this is
powerful so I read there's these little
old books on you know this little old
lady wrote these books she things about
health and spirituality and I was
reading and she talked about the
benefits of of having a good posture and
how that had a moral influence on the
being well that you know it's it's
interesting well someone actually did a
study on it not because of what she said
they just did a study and what they
found is they had college students they
told them to every time they notice they
were slouching
they had them like recorrect their
posture and what they found is that
these college students found that they
were better able to overcome in other
areas of their life when they were
keeping good posture yes it's so easy
especially if you're working on you know
the same thing it's like we're sitting
there in the computer it's like you know
you start off you got good intentions
then after a while you're like feeling
like I'm feeling a bit down it's like
you're not getting any oxygen to your
brain you know that's just thing is we
actually moved to standing desks for
that reason also all of our desks are
standing that's it we could stand
because it just makes you like sit back
only you ever seen those commercials of
those like strappy things that you can
put like a man bra yeah doing something
a that's like do what you can to try to
figure it and maybe you'll get in the
habit of it yeah so yeah so how much
water now this is not a set in stone
this is from they call him doctor
because I don't know how to say his name
but you know from hit he wrote a book
called your body's many cries for water
and he suggested half your body weight
in ounces so meaning like if you weigh a
hundred pounds if you're like a you know
small lady hundred pounds you would
drink 50 ounces of water if you're 200
pounds maybe you drink a hundred and and
some say well maybe you should drink
like what where I should be your ideal
weight rather than because you know
you're 400 pounds and you're drinking
like 200 ounces of water might be kind
of hard but you might make eat less
because you know you're feeling you're
yes sure less food I mean my kids when
they start whining about food and stuff
like this that's the first thing we tell
them is like did you drink water like
drink some water and you won't be
screaming at us for
totally totally happy not feed my kids
but yeah yeah yeah I think people need
to learn that that's not a craving for
food it's actually craving for water
often often sure that's Michael Turpin
yeah we misinterpret and then people
start to snack and it just makes the
situation worse where is the water guys
weight loss yeah yeah yeah every Health
Program I sit in you know especially the
ones for diabetes they're always telling
you in between meals
drink water don't eat food that's right
and now and they've done a study on it
to find out so people who so same little
old lady told us to drink like some time
before the meal so that you won't feel
the need to during well they actually
someone did a study on it they had
people drinking a half an hour before a
meal in it I think it's the equivalent
of like your standard bottle like 16
ounces of like 2 cups of water a half an
hour before and people who did that they
there was a control group also did
something else and I think they imagined
being full before the meal was that the
control group but the people who just
drank two cups of water a half an hour
before the meal they ended up losing
like over ten pounds I believe are right
around ten pounds of weight just by
drinking before the meal I mean that's
significant so people I mean you know
you don't go into the meal totally
starving it yeah and it's like you me I
had three other brothers growing up in
our household so it's like when food was
set on the table it was like you didn't
get you didn't eat your food fast you
weren't gonna get any so I have I have a
hard time in need and slow down and you
know that that's probably a really good
trick to it is interesting so some
things that we encourage people to do to
overcome cravings because you know
you'll have that moment of temptation
you're craving something and there's
four things that we share to do right
then okay you know besides all the other
things we share that you're trying to
change your habits because we don't just
remove habits we replace them with
positive good habits that will increase
your health and yeah so one of them is
drinking water as we've said so
literally right then when you're feeling
down when you're feeling tempted
whatever have water with you all the
time it becomes your new best friend and
you think about a lot of our addictions
have to do with
your neural muscular think you know
right hand to mouth you know that's a
neuromuscular thing where it's like
muscle memory right and so now you've
got whether it's a smoking drinking
eating bad things biting your nails you
can actually form a positive habit of
handing out the similar similar motion
replacing something good yeah and so
you're trying to do a positive thing in
place of the negative one and and so
water like right then right there start
drinking it I had a friend of mine that
wanted to overcome smoking and she
always just would drive around in a car
with a fake cigarette and she would
actually like sit there and puff it like
it was like a real one and she'd blow
out I always thought it was like so
silly but she literally like that's how
she got old it's just killer faking the
action yeah and one thing they they say
that smokers might be getting more
oxygen because they're breathing so
deeply and so that that's literally one
thing that's that's helping them I mean
they should make oxygen hits cells rosin
like oxygen and then another thing is
walking or more intense exercise is even
better for young people if you're older
and that's all you can do great yeah but
so but just you know either let's say
there's a stressful situation get up
remove yourself go out and get some
fresh air and walk around you know
you're you're removing yourself you're
not trying to escape from the problem
you just realize I can't handle this
right now
and instead of going to your normal
addiction you remove yourself and go and
start walking and take your water with
you and start drinking and you know we
were made to move right from the
beginning God when he created Adam and
Eve would he put them in yeah turn ten
to a garden right we're made to make six
days yes and so now we sit a lot for
work you know historically people farmed
more and did things like that but today
we sit a lot we drive sitting we do
everything sitting and so our blood has
become sluggish
so now and we activity naturally
stimulates your blood
okay gets your muscles get your heart
moving and you get stimulated well now
we're looking for artificial stimulation
right right we look for it through our
food through our addictive substances
what have you we're looking for
artificial stimulation because we feel
dead right you know in our office we
have the standing desk so we kind of got
a little bit of movement out of it I
actually keep a weight by my desk and so
sometimes you know because if you if you
sit in front of a computer long enough
there's moments in our office where all
you hear is click click click click and
it's just an interesting world we live
in that we all make a living out of just
like literally oshina but it's like most
of our stuff is online and you know it's
like but I actually will lift weights
from time to time and just you know try
to challenge each other like ok drop
down and give me 20 you know like just
do so throughout the day that's great so
the next thing is breathing accurately
you know we were just talking about
getting away you know get some fresh air
having good posture so that you could
breathe accurately and Chad's gonna show
us just yeah one of the ways you can
find out too so we should be when you
look at a baby a baby you know baby
that's lying down their little tummy
goes up and down it looks like their
tummies going up and down you know
because a baby breeze you know a healthy
baby breeze normally the way they should
be breathing and so their tummy goes up
and down because their which is their
diaphragm is where they're doing deep
breathing naturally but as we get older
we might start getting more of a gut and
we don't want anybody to know so what do
we do we suck it in and then we start
she do this and we think all that that's
deep breathing because look my chest is
going up and down but the diaphragm is
not expanding as it should be as much as
it should be and so the way to feel if
you're not used to it to feel your
diaphragm is if you put your arms
between your legs like this and you
literally just bend over I feel like the
chair will tip over if I do it too far
but nevertheless and then take a deep
breath you can feel it it feels like
it's breathing into your stomach out
there I mean it's not your stomach it -
it's filling the diaphragm so that
feeling is is your diaphragm so you want
to learn to stand straight and one of
the ways to
to learn to stand straight a fee if you
were to stand up is literally put your
arms to your sides and just reach up
like this you reach up and then you put
your arms back down and it puts you into
a proper standing position so or sitting
for that matter so you do that
I guess my shirts coming up here but
nevertheless when you do that you have
proper positioning of your you know your
body and then as you breathe you want to
learn to feel that diaphragmatic
breathing so you're actually breathing
and we're not talking this is not like
Nessa something we're just learning to
breathe the way we were designed to
agree and we're actually told that many
people they start feeling down during
the day and one of the simple reasons is
because they're just you know they're
not breathing properly they're not
getting adequate oxygen oxygen to the
brain and bodily organs so it seems all
the more important to follow these
things because the way society is
progressing at least Western society
we're already putting ourselves at a
deficit yeah so you know if we're not
moving around how much more important is
that we have good posture tell us we're
just sitting at our desk yeah if we're
you know if we're you know not breathing
properly because of our posture yeah
it's like the deck is almost being
stacked against us so because of the
choices you know the lifestyle choices
I'm going to make so it's that much more
important that we do these things
instead of like having a coke at the
desk we need our water so we can make
sure that blood flow is good totally
because we're not necessarily up and
moving around all the time either
exactly and what you don't realize is
when you're tempted or when you get
angry and you're tempted to yell at
somebody or something your breathing
becomes shallow your heart rate goes up
your blood pressure increases and that's
how you feel when you're tempted but you
don't realize all that you're not like
oh my heart's doing that you know but
this is what's happening and hence why
it's important not to have these
addictive substances in your body
because it makes you have that all the
time makes your heart rate go up if
you're shallow breathing blood pressure
goes low pressure goes up and so that's
how you feel so when you're in that
state of mind or in that state of your
body your state of mind is affected
because
you're not getting the blood flow you
need and so that's why a lot of times
when you're attempted you make the wrong
decision yeah and that's why we just say
drink your water get up and walk
do your accurate breathing right so if
somebody's getting mad at you just even
not when I go to the doctor and I have
to have my blood pressure taken I can't
handle it I hate that pressure on my arm
so I do deep breathing during that time
I'm just like interesting I'm gonna
breathe so that I can calm down and it
lessens the pain but it also brings my
blood pressure down hmm where normally
that would just make my blood pressure
rise because the pain that comes into my
arm from that so and and you can do that
if you have some kind of pain in your
body you know you breathe accurately and
you'll get the oxygen to that area of
the body and then you just more relaxed
but with all that said you know we we
talk about all these things and they're
important but let's say you know we
talked in our seminar people who have
been in concentration camps and things
like that they don't have good drinking
water right there they can't get out
there they might be in really couldn't
give a chance yet it's really like
torture in a box for months literally
okay and the air is stale what what do
they do do they just give up right yeah
this is the thing that we tell people
Bible promises and prayer is your key
yep right because you may not have that
all at your disposal but you always have
that connection with heaven when I was a
kid we had a our church property there
was a house that was like right next
door to the church property and there
was a guy who used to work at one of the
local hospitals and he he was real
friendly kind of elderly gentleman and
in his old age he lost his eyesight and
then he lost his hearing so he was both
blind and deaf at the same time and he
would lay in his bed and recite the
Bible verses that he had and as kids we
would go over to his house and I can
remember there as a 6 years old
literally this guy sitting in his bed
smiling and just literally
reading like the Bible like in his head
and he was happy that's plan if you
screamed into his ear you know he could
kind of make out who you were and stuff
and he remembered but it was one of the
ways that did just kept him going and
I'm he lived that way for years oh yeah
we share stories about like this this
guy in he was in the Vietnam War and he
was shot two shot down and he you know
you're eating almost stale rotten food
he said you're in a room you're in
solitary confinement he said you're just
trying to keep your sanity because
there's nobody to talk to there's
nothing to do it's just this same color
room and you start people going insane
you know from solitary confinement and
he said I found found in those times how
important it is like you know thinking I
mean thinking is really I mean like
that's the center of who we are right
you know and so he said man I started
going over Bible verses and he said it
basically he said I wished I had
memorized more verses before I came into
this torture camp you know he said but
he didn't know I mean the realities
partly we do know what comes into the
future of this world there's some
serious stuff coming and so I'm not
saying just memorize verses for the
future but we need the we need the
promises of God we need verses right now
for temptation Jesus you know and that's
right int the only way he was able to
overcome those temptations was with the
Word of God that's right Jesus said it
is written when the devil came with the
temptation we can say the same thing so
we may be struggling with you know
thoughts of cigarettes or drugs alcohol
pornography whatever and the Bible tells
us it tells us that like we said you
know that we are renewed by in our minds
Romans 12 verse 2 you know be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
and so the Bible says that we can find
Bible verses you can look them up you
can google you know Bible verses on
temptation Bible verses on lust Bible
verses on addiction and you'll find
something that whenever you're tempted
you can either pull it out of your
pocket but even better if you read it
over out loud 10 times a day and then
try to go over it 10 times from memory
after several days of doing that you'll
have it memorized
you got to keep going back to it or I'll
fade away but 10 times a day reading it
out loud 10 times a day
trying to quote it out loud and it will
start to just stick in your mind because
if you're really really tempted you're
probably not gonna be like let me go
find that card in my wallet or let me
open up my phone and find it by that
time you might be looking at something
you shouldn't or you might already it's
to put the cigarette in your mouth you
know but instead having that verse right
there on the tip of your tongue yeah
Jesus had it in his mind and he was able
to fire that off
he didn't say like oh yeah yeah there's
a scroll on this Syria what's
interesting about the example of Jesus
too is if you think about his immediate
situation in context he was hungry
mm-hmm he's likely thirsty yeah right
for so he's already at a deficit for
water yes which means you know walking
is probably not the most fun thing right
now yeah and breathing accurately is
probably not gonna be the first thing on
his mind so it's like these Bible
promises and prayer was like the
paramount family that he needed in that
situation because everything else he's
at a deficit huh and so this is the most
important no question the other things
are something we should do on a
day-to-day basis while we're in freedom
why do we have the opportunity we want
to give us our bodies the best fighting
chance and doing all the other things
well can over time make it a habit of
doing what's right so your mind get
because let's say you're a negative
person and maybe it's partly because
you're always slouching you're eating
bad food and you're you know you're not
getting you never have the window open
you don't drink water so you're drinking
junk and so so you get in habit of
negative thoughts but then when you
start changing those things and over
time you start to have better thoughts
so let's say you go into a very
seriously difficult situation at that
point it will be easier because you
remember it's happens you know thoughts
work out actions or repeated actions
form habits and habits form character so
as you do that in by God's grace in the
future as we go to his promises it'll
just be a habit to do that he'll just be
a part of who we are like oh we return
to God's Word as simple as breathing we
turn to him you know you always have
some thoughts going in the back of your
mind
even while we're talking you always have
that can be your prayer life okay you
know those communication communication
with heaven where it says pray without
ceasing that's the way we
can do that right and and having that
connection so that when the bad times
come you know where to turn you're not
turning back to your substance you're
not turning back to the thing that shuts
down your mind you're turning to Jesus
who opens your mind makes you think
deeper and find a solution that's right
I'm gonna scroll quickly through a few
things just to basically you know Thomas
Edison said I know 999 ways not to make
a light bulb meaning like hehe failed
and failed and failed but it wasn't
really failure it was a learning
experience so you know don't give up
just because you stumble but I want to
give you just a couple thoughts the
Bible says in Philippians 4:13 I can do
all things through Christ which
strengthens me
no matter what we struggle with no
matter what and I mean no matter what
Jesus can give us the victory we may say
but I'm born this way this is just who I
am Chad don't you recognize I was born
this way the reality is is maybe you
were right yeah it doesn't matter
meaning
so if great-grandpa was an alcoholic
grandpa was an alcoholic your dad was an
alcoholic is it possible that you may
have either a genetic or an epigenetic
tendency toward that I believe you could
first and I think that could be the case
with any sinner but the reality is is
just because I was born that way
does that mean God can't give me the
victory right no God can give the
alcoholic the victory or any other issue
that you struggle with when it says I
can do all things through Christ which
strengthens me it really means all
things right you know and I'm gonna give
you a couple challenges to finish this
up actually a pride 3 this is a study
from the American Journal of Public
Health this is on your change in life
satisfaction how happy you are depending
on how many servings of fruits and
vegetables you eat in the day
interesting this is a legit study from
and this has been replicated this two
studies have been done on this I think
the first was in Australia and then you
have this one you know that's you know
written in the American Journal of
Public Health and so if you eat zero
pieces of fruit or vegetables in a day
you're statistically the least happy
you're gonna be that day if you eat one
serving it makes you just a tiny bit
happier I'm guessing you don't want to
stop there right you know like it
doesn't look that great does it and so
you eat too you eat three you eat four
five six seven eight pieces or servings
rather it's actually
servings of fruits or vegetables in a
day and it makes you significantly
happier and so back to our whole point
of addiction is so we know that what you
eat we know that what you put in your
mouths can make you think about alcohol
can make you feel either happy for a
moment or whatever but it fades away you
you put a you know marijuana in your
mouth it makes you feel happier
temporarily it doesn't actually make you
a long-term app or you you know you do
you know do various drugs that you you
know you can cocaine or whatever you can
take them in different forms but you get
the point we know that things we ingest
can change our level of happiness at
least temporarily and even this is
temporary but the good news is you
become happier this this they did two
studies on this one of them show that
not only did it make you happier the day
you ate it
if we're told how happy you would be the
next step it's like sustained happy
exactly interesting to me is it's like
we do we get ourselves into all these
addictions because we want to feel good
and you're a scientific evidence of
here's how you feel good yet people
fight against this all the time and it's
like I'd rather have the you know the
junk food to try to get there but it's
like a big drop yeah exactly like it
might feel good while you'd eat it but
you don't feel good after you eat the
junk food what's fascinating about this
is exercise is the same way
totally totally you know you exercise
and there's a lasting benefit the next
day yeah so if you keep it up you have
this perpetual lasting effect that keeps
going in your life that's that's the
point like we were with a young lady in
Norway just a few weeks ago and she was
talking about you know she's like here
we just you know we just have sex with
people you just have sex with someone
and then and if you like it with them
you maybe do it again and then maybe you
think of dating them you know so it's
not even like dating it's just sex you
know and but then she told us and then I
looked up the study to find out you know
because people say things you know just
cuz something said doesn't mean it's
true
so we try to find legit scientific
studies you know and so they found that
people the more one-night stands you
have you become negatively impacts your
mental health
now if evolution were true the happiest
people on the planet would be people who
just have sex with everybody right yeah
right man I'm spread my genes everywhere
you know but does it happen no no
statistically they become more unhappy
right and so meaning it doesn't make
anything the greatest satisfaction is
within the marriage context that's exact
shoe election is heightened within a
marriage context which once again if
evolution were true that would make no
sense like you better spread that gene
pool but not true right you don't find
peace and joy from that and I don't
believe it's just you know old society
tells us that no society doesn't tell us
that anymore the old Christian values
are gone for most of society so we don't
live in like a Christian you know nation
much anymore you know some people are
Christian for sure but the reality is
these things that we do that take there
it takes diligent effort to eat a lot of
fruits and vegetables right yeah it
takes diligent effort you know not to
sleep around and not to get divorced or
whatever it takes it's difficult you
know and they've also found that people
who stick out a marriage where they're
not even happy now we're not saying you
know like someone's run around sleeping
around there are biblical reasons why
you can see divorced we get that and if
somebody's really hurting you you don't
have to stay with that person in that
house it's not safe to do something like
that we get that we're not talking about
that but the reality is this people who
are just just not happy in their
marriage you know we're not talking
about terrible situations that that ten
years later that they're statistically
happy so like people who actually like
go through the difficulties of marriage
and stick it up end up statistically
being happy you know what I'm saying
every time but statistically that it's
okay okay these difficult things can
actually make it easier so this is a
terrible little chart put out here
because you can hardly see it but never
less so this is this is a suggestion for
two weeks on lowering levels of
depression so for one day if you're not
a serious drug addict alcoholic or
diabetic this is for normal healthy
people so for one day you go on a fruit
diet and if you're if you're up to it
you could actually go on a temporary
fast skip a meal or two before you do
this and then you could go a day or two
on a fruit diet and this will increase
your happiness rather quickly like we're
talking about with this chart we just
saw with you so the first day and it's
very easy to digest so it's easy on the
gut and we talked about this in our gut
brain yes you want to eat plenty don't
think like a banana and Apple as a meal
you need to eat til you are literally
comfortable your body will actually tell
you when
enough is enough totally as opposed to
if you eat like junk food
you can't yeah it's you could fill up
like eat the whole bag and you still
feel hungry yes you try doing that with
some bananas yes you only need so many
totally totally we would rather have
people in general eat two to three meals
a day but if you're just eating fruit
you may eat more if you have two not you
don't want to get into that habit but in
general you know you want two to three
meals a day at most but but for fruit
you might have to do a little more
especially if you're not used to it but
eat enough so that you're not like you
know blood sugar spikes and then drops
or mostly the drop is what you're
running so the first date you do fruit
maybe two days and then you move on the
next one to a fruit and vegetables so
try to have fruit meals veggie meals and
so now you're you're adding to your
microbiome the gut bacteria right you're
getting that so then the next day after
that you move on to fruits veggies
aren't you already doing that and then
well cooked whole grains now if you're
someone who has celiac disease or you
can't eat gluten you can avoid the
gluten grains and you can you can eat
other things that don't have gluten but
for most people 90 plus percent of the
of people do find with gluten so you're
eating well-cooked whole grains because
undercooked grains can actually be hard
on the gut so if you're eating grains
I've heard that about oatmeal yeah like
actually oatmeal needs to be cooked a
long period so it does have to be cooked
for a lot what happens if you like
Vitamix it and blend it down though you
don't change it it's a good question I
don't I don't know for sure
but in general it's better to have a
well cooked it is because it breaks down
I can't remember the name but it's
something that preserves it for the next
year's harvest your art to be planned it
to be planned yeah okay so you want to
break down those is it Sakura no I
forget the name sorry that's okay but
you want to break that down and cookie
cookies and actually prolonged cooking
works and the same with beans okay yes
well do you really really don't so if
you get gaseous off the beans you didn't
cook it long enough yeah or two long
enough oh yeah there's the other key is
that lighting just to be honest I used
to have terrible terrible gas with beans
but if you chew them more like
significant amount and just it really
helps with the digestion significantly
so
the next day you add so you got any
fruits veggies well cooked whole grains
and then you add beans or legumes to it
and you want those also to be well
cooked and day five is add nuts and
seeds to what you've had everything a
lot not a lot
typically one handful of nuts is really
all you need if you're super exerciser
to you know to maybe a little more but
but eating handful after handful is
actually not probably the best thing for
you to do with nuts there it's just not
as concentrated isn't it's more because
there's a significant amount of fat in
there so but then for it's a total of
two weeks six you know day six today 14
you continue on with everything else so
you you have day five you know basically
day four plus day five and you continue
to see you're on a whole food
plant-based diet for two weeks and
statistically it will lower depression
levels by 50% within two weeks a study
has been done on that and so you can if
you're potentially I don't know if that
means you're 50% happier but if you are
you're less likely to feel the need for
the cigarette for the drugs for another
person have sex with or whatever your
pornography whatever your addiction is
or something we haven't mentioned when
you're happy or you're less likely to go
back to your destructive habit right so
that's a review there this is quite
powerful from a book called spark the
revolutionary new science of exercise in
the brain which imagine exercise
exercise improves learning on three
levels first it optimizes your mindset
to improve alertness attention mood and
motivation second it prepares and
encourages nerve cells to bind to one
another which is a cellular basis for
logging in new information and third it
spurs the development of new nerve cells
from stem cells in the hippocampus
Meeny exercise can enhance your memory
also so if it makes less stress you're
gonna be less likely to have to go to
your substance or whatever your you know
your addiction is so exercise two of the
other things too number one try the diet
it can be unless your doctor says not to
you know whatever but most people can do
this and two weeks and you say well what
after the two weeks if you want to live
the healthiest the longest the closer
you get to a plant-based diet for the
rest of your life it the longest living
people on the planet are actually people
who
moved closer to a plant-based diet they
are the longest living people on the
planet you know I seen a just a new
trailer recently for a documentary it
starts out very provocative and it has I
think Arnold Schwarzenegger opening and
they're talking about you know
everything that we've been told about
protein from an athletes perspective has
been wrong and they talked about how
they were told to eat lots of meat and
all this stuff and then you find out you
know in this trailer you're seeing like
a significant portion of the Tennessee
Titans foot that's right like you guys a
plant-based diet guys if totally like
ball players and professional ista level
you know they're come there saying why
didn't I do this sooner and they're
there their energy goes up the recovery
rates are faster it is so much better
and so the only American who made it to
the Olympics in weightlifting in his
class the only one is a vegan not one
meat-eater in the nation could do can do
better than this guy who just hates
plants Wow
you know there's another guy broke the
world record of Patrick I don't know how
to say his last name but bohmian or
something he carries 555 kilograms which
is like 1,100 pounds he carries it for
like 10 meters 30 feet or whatever he
drops it and he yells vegan power breaks
the world record and so look at the
point is you don't have to be as skinny
as me to the new plant-based diet you
can it's easier to be skinny on a
plant-based diet but the reality is you
don't have to I mean you can you can you
can become massive look at that Rhino
rhino eat plants yeah everything is a
massive an elephant they look up and
then they have endurance like you
wouldn't believe they can run all night
like 20 miles an hour all night with
that massive so going back to the food
thing a little tip you know I think is
good for people is you you you you want
to eat this way yes but what's important
so you don't fall back into your regular
habits is make a list first like make a
meal plan yeah or find a meal plan yeah
because you go to the girl you need to
go to the grocery store you need to buy
everything and you need to start making
it otherwise if you try to do it like
day by day or try to remember you're
gonna fall back into your yeah
yes yeah I'm just gonna eat whatever
because it's simple it's convenient it's
what you're used to
so always recommend you know if you have
a trouble that way especially if you're
single you know if you're single you
cook for one you're just grabbing stuff
but try to get a meal plan in place
they're all over the Internet
yep and they're they're easy so put a
meal plan in place so that you help
yourself succeed otherwise you just pull
back and also make sure you bring food
with you yeah usually if you're in a
hurry you grab isn't always healthy one
thing I want to state which I'm not
gonna go into now because it'll be too
much to talk about the physiology of it
but if you if somebody really struggles
with lust pornography or anger this will
sound crazy but try avoiding spicy food
for two months okay that sounds great so
do you guys have material on this
whether it is in your videos yeah yeah
yes okay so we will put the link in the
description below because this is a
really interesting topic and and we
probably don't have time to come down
right now but check out this link of
this ministry anchor port films.com
you guys will be absolutely blown away
at some of this material I know Chad and
Fatih have shared some of this
information with me before but very
interesting spicy foods and the link to
lust very interesting yeah so it's you
know long story short try implementing
some of these things and you may find
some of the same benefits that I have
and people wouldn't we've been able to
work with around the world teaching this
is just so you know this is part we've
looked at one message of like five or
six hours around six hours of material
so there's so much more this is just
like the cusp of what's in there but
there's so much we can do but even these
simple things can make a significant
impact on our cognition one more study
on exercise the cutting the cravings in
half yeah they found that they found
them
marijuana smokers who didn't want to
quit marijuana they got them in an
exercise regimen a cardio exercise
program of exercise and it lowered their
cravings by 50% for marijuana and they
didn't even want to quit that's the
amazing it's one thing Americans want to
quit and exercise lowers if these guys
don't even want to quit any lowers
that's a huge so what's interesting is
because like it seems like the more
the marijuana that you smoke you you
don't seem too motivated so true amazing
this time you're motivated and you're
like I don't know I don't want to not be
motivated totally totally awesome you
guys thank you so much for sharing I
mean what an awesome awesome
introduction to this topic if you guys
have more questions on the topic of
overcoming addictions check out Anchor
Point films calm these guys have done an
extensive amount of research awesome
documentaries they've got prophetic
documentaries that talk about prophecy
and what the Bible has to say about that
and some pretty amazing work you guys
have been traveling around and sharing
those messages
Chad fatiah thank you guys so much for
coming by and being on her show and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and if you guys want leave a
comment below try out the diet that Chad
and foggy have put on the screen over
here
you know just pause it on there and take
a screenshot or write those things down
and just give yourself a week or two and
try I mean all of us have struggled with
addiction at some point in time I know I
personally have and these things that
were brought up today are very
achievable very simple ideas everyone
has water access to fresh air walk
outside exercise you know if you can
just tweak a couple of your things in
your diet start eating more fruits and
vegetables give that a try and you will
see literally a change in two weeks yeah
three weeks try that out alright thank
you guys for watching remember LED live
hit that subscription button and share
this with all your friends we'll see you
guys later
[Music]